en milieu d'après-midi le bruit d'une
explosion a pu être entendue dans
plusieurs quartiers de 2 me est sur
internet et des rumeurs ont couru comme
quoi cette explosion avait eu lieu dans
le centre ville mais très rapidement les
autorités locales ont fait savoir que ce
n'était pas le cas mais c'est une
explosion qui avait eu lieu au niveau de
la ligne de contact par contre je peux
vous raconter la façon dont j'ai vécu
les événements j'étais alors assis un
café et au moment de l'explosion c était
en fait un bruit sourd et lointain et
bien lieu comme une pause les gens se
sont regardés ont regardé par la fenêtre
il ya eu des ossements des pôles et très
rapidement les gens ont repris le fil de
leurs conversations cela montre bien
d'après moi la façon dont tous ces gens
ont intégré le bruit de ces explosions
ils font partie de la vie quotidienne
alors que globalement nous sommes allés
à la rencontre de ces gens un peu plus
tôt dans la journée ils nous ont raconté
la façon dont ils vivent cette escalade
des tensions
moi je ne sens rien ma famille est calme
je suis médecin est là où je travaille
ça va mais en fait une certaine angoisse
se fait sentir
en
réalité je crois que comme n'importe
quelle personne qui vit tout simplement
ici l'essentiel ce n'est pas ce qu'on
dit mais ce qui se passe en réalité
présent il n'y a pas d'aggravation dont
on parle dieu merci ça continuera comme
ça
cela me préoccupe mais je sais que les
gars qui ne protège ici ne laisserons
personne nous attaquer
ce sont des nouvelles très triste qui ne
nous rend pas du tout et je souhaiterais
de la stabilité mais bien sûr la
diffusion de ces nouvelles nous rend
tristes
malgré cet état de vives tensions la pu
entendre plusieurs appels au calme comme
celui lancé par le ministère ukrainien
des affaires étrangères par contre sur
le terrain on le sent très bien se
calmer tout à fait relatif